all right in today's morning rounds new
guidelines say most people should start
colorectal cancer screening earlier the
American Cancer Society says testing for
men and women at average risk should
begin at age 45 instead of 50 the change
comes in response to a 51 percent rise
in colon and rectal cancers since since
1994 in adults younger than 50 our dr.
Jon LaPook is a gastroenterologist who
does this kind of screening John good
morning so what does that mean average
risk average risk are basically people
it's most people people who don't have a
high risk a high risk would be somebody
with a family history of colon cancer or
somebody has a certain genetic condition
where you have a certain kind of
inflammatory bowel disease and we get
even tested earlier those have tested
even earlier say at 40 or even earlier
that that's something you specifically
talk about with your doctor why has
there been this dramatic rise in colon
and rectal cancer yeah that is the
million-dollar question you know some
people wonder is it obesity is the lack
of exercise diets something in the
environment what I think is really
interesting is the possibility it's the
microbiome so the trillions of bacteria
that are in our gut and there's one to
two thousand different species and it
turns out that certain of those species
are linked to an increased risk of colon
cancer and when you think about it we
have been changing our microbiome we
take antibiotics our diet has changed
and one of the theories is that we're
we're messing up our microbiome and
increasing the risk that way that's just
the theory but John this is a really big
deal because I've always been told that
you get it at 50 and I've had three of
them as you know dr. LaPook it's so
funny we were in the green room this
morning and Nour it goes so Jon LaPook
is your doctor I go at the time we were
not working together because I might not
have made that decision to have you now
I know you've given her colon ah three
different occasion I would not have said
that I want you to say just publicly
I've never revealed that that you do but
you've always said to me that it's it's
99.9 percent preventable if it's caught
in time so this is a big deal to lower
put it in perspective about what these
numbers really mean the numbers are
really
astounding because you think about what
we're talking about screening another 21
million yeah when the reason is that
even though we're doing better so over
the age of 55 we're doing great with
screening removing these precancerous
polyps before they become cancer using
colonoscopy and the rates of colon
cancer deaths and the number of cases
going down over 55 at the same time
they've been going up and up and up in
younger people and if you were born in
1990 you have twice the risk of getting
colon cancer as if you were born in 19
and there are certain groups blacks
Alaskan Natives American Indians who
have an increased risk just to start off
with for some reason and it's great to
be more more aggressive in those groups
to quickly Johnna there any warning
signs other than that you discover
through a procedure I'll tell you the
warning sign of a polyp is I'm feeling
perfectly fine but the warning sign of
cancer which you don't want to get to
that point are bleeding changing your
stool now ershov abdominal discomfort
weight loss discomfort you know an
anemia the unknown cause usually from
iron deficiency because you're you're
losing blood so if you're not feeling
well obviously always talk to your
doctor and say hey what's going on you
gotta figure out a better way to do that
prep it's so god-awful Gail that prep
beats chemo yeah you're right you're
absolutely right about it dr. Jon LaPook
delivering the truth right here